bonjour à vous merci d'être avec nous en
direct ce matin sur rtl france d'abord à
propos du bilan humain qui s'annonce
terrible
au moins 600 personnes tuées au cours
d'un massacre perpétré par des miliciens
tigréens à mes cadres à localité du
tigré selon des informations de la
commission éthiopienne des droits de
l'homme donc un [ __ ] donc ce massacre
à milices de jeunes tigréens et des
forces aussi de sécurité loyales aux
autorités locales
que faut-il penser justement de ces
conclusions de cette commission
éthiopienne des droits de l'homme je
crois que je crois que ce qu'on peut
noter au porteur c'est on a affaire à
deux camps qui sont extrêmement motivés
extrêmement motivés qui s'estime
légitime filiation habib ahmed un des
premiers ministres et qui avec les
autorités avec le par mais nationale ici
de reconquérir cet espace tigréens qui
s'est mis qui s'est mis en dissidence
avec l'idée petit monsieur les pressions
et qui est lui-même aussi très motivé
qui s'estime légitime et qui sans
pouvoir légitime alors que le premier
ministre éthiopien lui et lui conteste
je crois que ce qu'il faudra retenir
c'est que le bilan humain était
certainement déjà très lourd et que
compte tenu de la motivation des deux
acteurs cotés
ça risque d'être encore beaucoup plus
lourd parce que c'est compliqué d'avoir
des informations sur ce qui se passe
dans la région puisque c'est compliqué
pour les journalistes d'accéder
justement à cette région en conflit
oui c'est une c'est une région qui est
quand même et non pas isolés mais assez
loin de d'addis abeba qui est quand même
assez difficile d'accès grande vallée
qu'il faut traverser donc déjà déjà
c'est assez compliqué
de didier accéder et ensuite situation
là bas qui est pas qui est pas celle du
tout enfin tous les tous les articles de
souligner les uns s'estiment les tigres
et un ont du mal à se passer du pouvoir
que leur avait donné mélès zenawi quand
il n'a pu renverser vague l'histoire
avec démaria mais qui pendant 25 ans
appliqué pour la première fois de
l'histoire de ce pays
c'est des tirs aériens tenez le pouvoir
du pays et le remplacement donc de du
premier ministre récemment depuis deux
ans par habib ahmed qui est un ormeau
inquiète anormaux et ben se passe passe
très mal il est mal acceptée par les
tirs et un kiki de conteste cette cette
perte de pouvoir et il s'estime légitime
chez eux estime légitime mourou tigré et
ne devait pas entendre parler du pouvoir
et y aucun --et et habib ahmed lui il
est dans une situation où ils s'estiment
très légitimement en charge de l'unité
du pays et est bien avec les moyens
qu'il a estimé devoir prendre
il essaie de remplir ses missions donc
de retrouver redonner à cette utopie à
une unité
alors justement le premier ministre
éthiopien bien med a lancé un ultimatum
un ultimatum qui expire aujourd'hui à
quoi faut-il s'attendre maintenant à je
crois que il est très motivé comme je
vous le disais il va aller au bout des
choses
la ville daddy g des jaquettes une ville
du pays est déjà tombé là ils
s'approchent de makalé donc ma a laissé
la capitale du tigré sens du loup il est
très motivé ses troupes sont très
motivés il a été rejoint cette troupe
joint par des milices amara maras et les
grands c'est les grands rivaux
c'est les grands rivaux des tigres est
un ce sont les gens des hauts plateaux
ce sont eux qui ont toujours pouvoir du
tendon ce rappel l'aï laissé l'acier on
se rappelle aussi de son succès c'est
ensuite qu'on appelait le négus rouge à
blâmer une disto et les variables sont
les amharas
et samara sont venus renforcer l'armée
nationale donc pas de doute de ce côté
là du côté d'albi ahmed on est très
motivé et vous l'avez compris de l'autre
côté mais de l'autre côté tout autant et
bien évidemment qu'est-ce qui est au
milieu
c'est la population et la population va
sacrément souffrir beaucoup de réfugiés
justement l'onu s'inquiète de cette
situation notamment humanitaires du
bilan humain on en parlait mais à l'onu
où il ya des divisions et un conseil de
sécurité sur ce conflit
hier les africains et notamment les
européens sont divisés sur la question
les africains souhaiteraient plus de
temps justement à la médiation de
l'union africaine quelles sont ses
chances
ben oui parce que il faut aussi
comprendre que ce ce conflit il se
passerait si dans ce pays qui est un peu
hâtif part en afrique et qui d'ailleurs
le siège de l'union africaine le siège
de villes africaines il à addis abeba il
est à quelques centaines de kilomètres
au sud du front qui a il ya dans une
sorte d'amour propre des africains de
vouloir entend faire en temps à la
communauté internationale qui sont
parfaitement capables de régler eux
mêmes ce problème et qu'on laisse le
temps et la chance de pouvoir mener
cette médiation
je crois que la plupart des pays
européens sont sur cette ligne là mais a
au nations unies donc un concert des
nations n'est pas y'a rien il ya des
voix qui sont qui sont plus moins dix
corps de guy scott
merci beaucoup à vous bruno clément
envolée consultant international
spécialiste de l'afrique